a number of years ago a young girl burst
into movies wearing a sweater in such a
way the International wool market lead
15 points later a young actor appeared
as maverick on television and made lace
front dress shirts a sign of virility
today these two fashion pacesetters are
firmly established as versatile screen
stars of the first magnitude
beautiful Lana Turner and gorgeous James
Garner
thank you Robert
that's all no jokes well why start a
trend
I'll go dressed my wounds dressing as
what we are here to honor the Wardrobe
created by those artists with skill and
imagination designed the costumes that
help that's all fulfill our roles first
the best achievement and costume design
and a black and white picture the
nominees are Julie Harris for darling
boss may bring the moratorium Mouse
mabry nor too hard we love you just flew
in love Howard shoot for Rage to live
bill Thomas Regina we worship fools
eat ahead for this Linda thread it sings
Dudley Edith Head from slender thread
and now for the winner Jim would you
open the envelope thank you
the costume design you think they'd have
a tassel tassel on the envelope the
winner is Julie Harris for darling
accepting on behalf of Julie Harris
Connie Steven
I know how excited miss Harris will be
when she receives her Oscar not only is
the Oscar one of the world's or the
motion picture world's what's going on
behind me both of us really in unison I
know how excited miss Paris will be
not only is the Oscar one of the highest
awards in the motion picture world but
it is one of the greatest honors in the
world of fashion since much of the most
exciting thinking in design is done by
film people thank you very much thank
you in the name of Miss Julie Harris
well now let's see some examples of the
wardrobe nominated for best achievement
and costume design of a color picture
from the credit story ever told
costumes by Vittorio Nino no present and
Marjorie best
dr. Zhivago costumes by Phyllis doll
The Sound of Music top soup party
costumes by Dorothea Jenkins the agony
and the ecstasy costumes by Victoria me
no no racing again inside Daisy clover
costumes by Edith Head and Bill Thomas
would you read this one I please learn
thank you the winner is
Phyllis Dalton for dr. Zhivago on behalf
of Phyllis Dalton Kathryn Grayson will
accept the award
on behalf of miss Phyllis Dalton I would
like to say thank you very much thank
you